bonjour mais où la deuxième ville
d'ukraine et est donc bombardé depuis
des semaines et c'est toujours le cas
oui absolument ici les explosions sont
quasi permanente les habitants sans
armes et se réveille en attendant des
déflagrations et aujourd'hui il continue
les ukrainiens à tenir évidemment la
ville de kharkiv qui est la deuxième du
cred vous l'avez dit qu'ils comptaient
environ un million et demi d'habitants
avant la guerre aujourd'hui environ un
tiers ou 40 % de ses habitants auraient
fui mais ils sont encore très nombreux à
rester alors les combats sont permanents
mais surtout à l'extérieur de karkhiv à
plusieurs kilomètres au nord et à l'est
les troupes russes pilote activement les
positions tenues par les ukrainiennes
mais les frappes sont finalement
totalement indiscriminée tous les jours
ce sont des des immeubles résidentiels
des stations essence parfois des
hôpitaux des crèches des écoles qui sont
touchés à tout moment ici à kharkhiv la
la mort peut tomber du ciel et les
habitants ont fini par s'habituer d'une
certaine manière à cet état d' à cet
état de choses ils entendent tous les
jours des explosions ont les ailes le
bilan humain est difficile à chiffrer
puisqu'une grande partie des corps sont
encore sous les décombres les services
d'urgence sont absolument débordées une
grande partie des habitants vivent dans
ce sous-sol beaucoup se terre dans le
métro beaucoup ont aménagé des abris
dans leur cave alors pour l'instant il y
à au moins 300 morts dans la région de
kharkiv probablement beaucoup plus des
centaines de blessés également un rien
qu'hier il y a eu au moins six morts
dans la ville de kharkiv et aux
alentours
bonjour romeo on voit derrière vous la
rue résidentielle dans laquelle vous
êtes semblables sans vie pourtant vous
le disiez il y à des habitants de
kharkiv qui sont restés
oui oui absolument comme je disais entre
30 et 40% des habitants sont restés
alors une grande partie à ceux qui sont
partis sont ceux qui avaient 20e en inde
et de la famille des contacts alouettes
ce qu'ils ont eu
argent la chance de pouvoir fuir à
l'étranger et met une grande partie ont
décidé de rester d'abord parce qu'ils ne
savent pas où aller mais aussi et
peut-être surtout parce qu'il s'agit
d'un acte de résistance à rester c'est
un montrer que la ville est encore
habité c'est pouvoir s'organiser en a à
l'arrière afin de pouvoir participer à
l'effort de guerre il ya ici des
centaines des milliers de volontaires
qui tous les jours font du pain cuisine
pour les militaires en n2 l'aide de
humanitaire à mettre de la nourriture
amène de l'eau au même des médicaments
dans les refuges où se terrent les
allées personnes allaient les habitants
des quartiers donc tous les jours il ya
ces actes de solidarité qui sont qui
force qui force le respect il faut le
dire un résilience et la bravoure des
habitants de kharkiv qui qui vivent sous
une pluie permanente de bombes sont
assez impressionnantes dont kkr qui les
gens sont encore là en revanche dans
certaines régions et notamment autour de
la région de cramât tusk qui se trouve à
un peu moins de environ 170 km au
sud-est de kharkiv la situation est très
critique puisque les forces russes sont
en train de masser leur lait toutes les
troupes qu'ils ont retiré de la région
de kiev la capitale sur le front de
karkhiv mais aussi à l'est avec pour
intention évidente d'arriver à prendre
la ville de craon 14 et toutes les
villes et toutes les villes proches donc
d'essayer de refermer cette nasse du
donbass au sein de laquelle se retrouve
une grande partie des forces sucré yens
donc dans la ville de tram à tort ce qu
en ce moment c'est l'exode là les routes
sont pleines de véhicules qui cherchent
à fuir la zone la gare est plein de
personnes qui essaient de également de
fuir leurs maisons de fürth leur ville
car les forces du craignent n le
gouvernement ukrainien c'est une
bataille extrêmement féroce va bientôt
se livrer et une recherche à avoir le
moins de six vite possible afin de
pouvoir présenter avec le minimum de
pertes humaines possibles
promeo langlois envoyé spécial de france
24 à kharkiv merci beaucoup roméo et on
salue 4